but before you go i do a segment where i  give every fight that comes on the show  some kicks from my wife at suplex and  philly  these are for you you got some fashion  on you  you know i couldn't let's go you're a  legend man these are legendary shoes  they're my favorite silhouette of all  times the jordan ones but they are  missouri tiger colors  oh yes and my boy said mr chandler  please wear these and enjoy these the  pollen jordan ones from suplex  philadelphia dude are you kidding me  lacking black and gold baby little  missouri tiger fighter  you were the man that's so sick weirdos  man i will dude so enjoy the kicks man i  can't wait for your next fight we gotta  get you on a calves fight companion  after your next fight right here  michael chandler ladies and gentlemen  from my wallet to my check i don't want  it if it's skinny but i need it  need  [Music]  super thick boy